you  gravity is working with me and gravity  he keeps me on the ground  Oh Massa tries all of the maths a force  proportional to mass one and two and  inversely to  the distance between them squared  whoa gravity he is working with me  in private  mix apples fall to ground  ah - why's the mass has twice the pull  with the boss on each is still equal  it keeps the moon and the satellites  going round  you  Oh twice the mass has twice football for  the force on each is still equal it  keeps the moon and the satellites going  round  whoa robbery the foursome makes weight  on me whoa reberty now general  relativity how can that be the pause  between us all is the boys between us  all this  the pause between us all is gravity  between us all is gravity between us all  is roti between gravity between us all  is